what's up believe nation welcome to
another AMA super pumped to be here this
is my new setup you guys get to see it
with the new camera look at how crisp
that is
I think shout out to Jeremy vest you can
plug in a DSLR camera right into your
computer and record from it I did not
know that
Jeremy bass gave me the tips on how to
do it but we've got half an hour
together it's a crazy busy day for me
and I want to make the most of it so
give me your questions pop it into the
live chat and I'll get to as many as
possible here we go number one what do
we got
sassy saying study motivations and tips
please
okay so study motivation first off try
to think back to my university days one
remembering why you're doing this like
the studying sucks I don't know anybody
who just loves studying you're
memorizing facts you're thinking wow why
am I doing this you know like everything
is right here where my when am I ever
gonna use this why am I just
regurgitating it's easier to get
depressed and negative on it just
remember the outcome like if you're
forced to do this or you really want
that outcome right you want to be a
doctor you have to study you have to go
to school it's just part of the process
so just remembering what you're trying
to get right remembering the outcome
remembering the goal remember the thing
that you're you're working towards and
having that drive you in terms of tips
one thing that really helped me was
having a schedule so knowing that this
time this day I'm gonna be studying make
your realistic schedule that works
something that you can still plan your
your extracurricular activities in your
family time your fun
clubs and studying and make that
schedule stick it's still something I do
today everything like I'm here because I
scheduled it in and I'm I'm planning my
whole day around this I'm doing events
and meetings and calls and zooms and
podcasts and a whole bunch of stuff all
day long but 12:30 p.m. Eastern for half
an hour I have in my schedule to be here
that's a commitment I made and I'll do
it for as long as I find that it's
valuable and helpful right and so
putting in your study time into your
schedule and then sticking to it I like
getting my week done early so if I'm if
I'm you I'm trying to study as much as I
can Monday to Friday get it done and
then you still have some time on Friday
night Saturday night to enjoy yourself
so I think what the family whatever
needs to get done but schedule it and
the other
a hack that I found was listening to
classical music on repeat I found super
helpful now in my business I we have the
nth vibe series where its productivity
music where it's like EDM music with the
beat but no lyrics and I find that that
helps me work productively when I was
studying I listened to Jurassic Park
soundtrack and who's the other one
Phantom of the Opera the Jurassic Park
original realistic Park part 1
soundtrack and Phantom of the Opera
Arnon tapes on tapes not even CDs wow
I'm getting old on tapes on repeats like
a tape would end I'd flip it and put it
in the other side and then switch to the
frames with the opera tape same thing
and then go back to Jurassic Park and I
found that that that really helped me
just having that classical music I think
classical music is actually better for
you for studying then praat then like
the productivity the EDM the stuff for
the beat so I found that really helped
me good luck next what do we got what we
got we got Lang logic Zack can you
expand on what we're talking about on IG
what you're thinking about creating
content like the content IG keeping it
consistent throughout so listen I'm
still relatively new on Instagram I'm
posting and posting a post and then
tasting and figuring that how to be
consistent is you create a schedule same
thing like everything else same thing
that the last the last comment if you
want to win guys you have big
aspirations you have goals you have
dreams you want these things to
accomplish look at your schedule are you
scheduling for success are the things
that are in your calendar like look at
your calendar if you did the things that
are in your calendar would it lead to
you getting results right like you want
to achieve this outcome look at your
calendar if you did the stuff this week
in your calendar will you get closer to
achieving that outcome if not then you
have to change the actions this is this
is the problem with motivation a lot of
times like Pete I went to Tony Robbins
seminar on 20 rounds is great he'll get
you all fired up and motivated but
that's not enough like to keep it
sustained the people who follow through
on it are the ones who then adjust their
schedule adjust their calendar so
there's something that you say is
important to you you put it in your
calendar and you dedicate time for it so
for me Instagram at the beginning
was doing everything every single post
every diem every comment everything was
me to to taste it to see what it's like
now I will post we post six times a day
my team does three of them and I do
three of them so in the morning I am one
of the first things I do as I wake up
and I go get a coffee
Timms hey Lily Lily's watching Lily's in
Thailand she can't have Tim Hortons I'll
get a coffee and then I walk back and
I'll make a quick message 15 seconds a
video and I post that to my Instagram
right that's that's repeat that's what I
do everything every morning right 11:30
I post a video so what it's an hour ago
I posted a video to my IG right and then
and then later in the afternoon I'll
post myself too so it's a my calendar I
get it done to make sure that that
happens every day and then it's just
tasting to see what works and what
doesn't work
when you're posting so much content
you'd start to get habits you got
certainly get trends start to pay
attention see what's working what's not
working
most people they can't they don't have
enough data to make an analysis because
they're just not posting enough content
you're not posting enough you're not
you're not out put in enough so you
don't know what's working and what's not
working as an example I do this live
stream every week pretty much this
actually hurts my channel I will lose
subscribers because of this video every
time I go live I lose subscribers can
perch a normal video so I keep doing it
well I keep doing because I like the
interaction I feel like the people who
do stick around who get value you get to
ask you one-on-one questions once a week
it's worth it so I have the data I know
I'm making data-driven decisions and if
if there's a reason to stick with a
series that's underperforming there's a
there's a reason for it
most people are not putting enough work
you're just not creating enough content
you need to know what the output that
you're putting out to see okay this is
working this isn't you start to adjust
so we go live four times a week I go
like four times a week on Instagram this
is the only day I don't go live on
Instagram because I'm gonna live with
you guys so this 12:30 spot Monday
Tuesday Wednesday Friday is Instagram
live and I love it I do it more why why
Instagram more than YouTube you even
know my YouTube buttons it's like
ginormously bigger because you can bring
people in because it's its face and face
because here I'm only responding the
text questions because YouTube the the
video giant hasn't figured out
how to bring video callers in for these
shows so I spend my time there and I
post six times a day and with YouTube I
post three times a day and in most
series don't work for every top ten
series that I have there's there's 98
failures that don't make it through the
top ten series started seven years after
I started my youtube channel it's crazy
seven years and what was I doing before
I was creating more content creating
more content creating more content so
you schedule it in you have to put in
the quantity and you start paying
attention to what's working as well as
what what vibe you get like are you
liking it because if you're just a slave
to the Machine you're not gonna be happy
either
good luck concentration tips please oh
hold on we got a super chat we got a
super stick we got a super chat anisha
$2 super chat Anisha this coffee's on
you you take a nice sip mmm
thank you for that any show okay do you
recommend the nine-to-five while working
on a dream so the reason you get a job
is to learn so I would highly recommend
getting the job where you can learn
about your industry you're learning
about the business you're basically
getting paid to make mistakes instead of
you launching a business and and failing
and making all those mistakes early you
learn by getting paid by somebody else
so I try to find a small company ten ten
employees or less not your startup like
one person isn't what they're doing but
not some giant corporation where if you
get started you're gonna be you're gonna
be an intern photocopying getting
coffees for people somewhere where it's
you look up to them they're ten people
are less you're gonna learn a lot from
them I thought that's how I would start
and I'd be starting my business on the
side I'd be working evenings to be
working weekends I think if you are
really desperate for money I think you
should get a job to start I think people
who are desperate for money you make
stupid decisions you make stupid
short-sighted decisions that impact your
business and prevent you from actually
making long-term money like the money
you will make in your business will come
from providing the insane value from
over delivering like crazy for your
clients and if you're constantly in
short term money mode it's really hard
to provide that value so I would try to
ease I would want to try to cut my
expenses so that I don't require a
I don't need a ton of income but then -
I'd get a job where it pays my base
needs and I'm learning about the
interstate I want to get in - don't get
a McDonald's job unless you want to
learn about the fast-food industry and
I'm certain my business on the side
that's my recommendation good luck thank
you for the super chat next coffees on
you uh ok next can you tell us a story
by the time when you were young when you
faced adversity and how you overcame it
the hardest part was starting my first
business I was 19 making $300 a month
not able to survive you know eating
beans for lunch every day I told my
business partner that I quit how I
overcame it was me feeling like I didn't
wanna live with regret so and it's still
the framework like I used that when I
was 19 years old and I'm I'm 38 years
old now looking at the date the 20 years
later almost 19 years later and it's
still the framework through which I make
my most important decisions I look at
and say am I gonna regret this like if I
don't give it one more day one more week
am I gonna regret it if you feel like
you gave everything you had to something
you can you can deal with it not working
at least for me if I felt like I gave
everything that I had and it didn't work
I could deal with it not working all of
the series that I've launched on my
youtube channel I just made a video
talking about the block excellent series
and the Samos and the girl boss failed
series they didn't work I love them we
poured tons of energy and heart and
passion into those videos and I was so
proud of every video that I made and it
didn't work out so I'm okay with
canceling that series I'm moving on to
something else
there's nothing that I feel like if I
did a little bit more even with those
ones normally give it three I gave those
ones I think five five episodes to test
its just didn't work out like okay I can
deal with that I can move on and so I
try to think that approach to life is
there's something that I'm quitting on
too soon if I feel like I haven't given
everything I've got then I have to go
off and do more because I know I'm gonna
regret it but if I look back on and say
you know what I'm okay with it I'm okay
I gave everything I had
I'm good it didn't work out awesome
to the next thing that's how he dealt
with it record I had to get rid of a
porn addiction
ooh that's a addiction is something I'm
not fantastic at the only thing that
comes to mind for me is one well one
like model success I'd find there's lots
of people talking about porn addiction
I'd find somebody who's gone through it
in and come out on the other side and
model their success the good news is
whatever problem you're facing right now
somebody's dealt with it why I love
showcasing all the different people on
my channel is a lot of the issues and
challenges that they face growing up and
building their business relate to you
you're going through it too so I would
find somebody who has a porn addiction
has talked about it and it's creating
content and studying learn from them and
then a lot of times with addiction is
also just finding something more
meaningful finding something more
valuable finding and finding your
purpose finding something that is more
addictive like I'm addicted to help in
entrepreneurs I'm addicted to doing this
I love the way I'm just sitting here in
an office by myself nobody's over here
today I'm by myself grinding out content
and being in interviews all day long why
I'm addicted to it I love it like I have
to do it you could pay me all the money
in the world if you said I couldn't do
this anymore I would not take it like I
have to do this so that's my best advice
Clifford Starks the $3 super chat
Clifford Starks I love it man next
coffee and a half is on you these costs
about two to thirty something like that
so like coffee in a bit is on Clifford
Clifford is starting the show podcast or
something I'm gonna be honest I may be
one of his first guests if not the first
one so Clifford says keep inspiring
others Evan your awesome friend thanks
for the love Clifford looking forward to
being on your show main and senior
success
okay next back to the regular questions
what do we got what do we got if you if
you are super chat stains out the most
then if you tag me it's it's easier for
me to see than just typing questions
William what are your thoughts on the
internet being oversaturated people
trying to make a career out of creating
I think it's a it's a don't buy into
that I think there's always room for
quality at the top always always always
always always always there's always room
for quality look at what I'm doing on
Instagram
Instagram is super saturated tons of
people lots of content being pumped out
daily what am i doing I'm coming in and
I'm gonna dominate this always room for
quality right now it's not overnight ik
domination I met I met I don't know how
many how many I met like nineteen
thousand subscribers or fans or whatever
yeah 19 thousand followers it's nothing
I mean it's something but it's nothing
compared to what I've done on YouTube
but I'm gonna post six times a day and
go live four times a week for four years
and I'm gonna make it there is always
room for quality the top in every
industry forever and ever amen if you
are bringing value you will win always
it is never oversaturated it's only
oversaturated with crap so don't bring
more crap you can either be first to
market and have something crappy and win
because there's no other option or you
can be later to market and have great
quality and win so I am very rarely the
first mover I'm very rare to the first
on a platform I like to see how
something works and if it's getting
traction then I'll come in and I'll just
do it better now you may not have the
skills yet to provide that thing that is
better so it's working on it like I'm
not I'm not a natural speaker talked
about a lot on this channel you could
watch my journey go back and look at my
first videos they were brutal I'm
introverted you know took me a long time
to get comfortable in front of the
camera all that stuff but you can
overcome it if I can overcome it you can
overcome it so never think it is over
saturation there is always over
saturation of crap and there's always
room for quality at the top next any
procrastination tips how to stop YouTube
addiction any tips for students who are
applying to colleges we kind of covered
some of this for students at the
beginning around studying
procrastination tips one I would say put
it put it in your calendar put it in
your schedule so that you have a working
schedule that is good for you that is
realistic that is achievable and that if
you follow through on that schedule you
will get the results that you're looking
for and to changing your identity to be
the kind of person who stomped out
procrastination anytime is this
is it this is the thing anybody's into
procrastination this is it anytime you
feel yourself procrastinating then you
have to go and do that thing even if you
barely want to do that thing just to
break the habit just to shift your
identity that's how you're gonna build
self-respect it's the same thing about
judgment if you feel yourself playing
small because of somebody else's opinion
then you have to go off and do that
thing even if you barely want to do that
thing here's what's gonna happen every
time you think about procrastinating and
then you procrastinate you're gonna
build that identity you're gonna lose
respect for yourself as I did it again I
did it again I did I procrastinate again
you're gonna lose respect you're gonna
lose respect for yourself every day
every time it happens you will lose more
respect for yourself
but if you say if you can catch it most
the time you won't even catch it but if
you can catch it and say I'm
procrastinating right now and then you
do the thing you start to respect
yourself every time you do it and it'll
become easier and easier and easier and
easier the next time you do it that's it
then and it doesn't start by one big
magical thing you go into the to the
weight room you start lifting little
weights like find one thing you
procrastinate now just do it and then
feel how great it is a great it feels to
do the thing if you've been
procrastinating for a week on doing
something or even the past what however
long it is been through today you've
been procrastinating on self and then
just do it how great it feels to do it
if I've had an unproductive day the best
thing I can do is have an next
productive day like if today was a write
off for whatever reason tomorrow I
guarantee you is gonna be the most
insanely productive day of all time
because that's the identity that I've
built for myself that's how I that's how
I wired myself it wasn't how I was wired
but it's how I wired myself and you do
that by training yourself that every
time you feel like you were
procrastinating you have to go off and
doble meant them on that thing otherwise
you lose respect for yourself next
Steven Harris with the super chat the
$1.99 Steven this coffee's on you
I appreciate it man that was a good sip
getting parched do you feel Facebook is
old
uh I would love more context on on that
so I can help you Stephen but Facebook I
see as the the best platform to do paid
campaigns I think if you are trying to
do organic reach Facebook is is while
probably the worst if you are a brand
and you trying to get organic reach with
your content like if you if you're a
pastor and you wanna you wanna film your
your what's not a speech what is it
sermon sermon if you want to film your
sermon and put them up I think Facebook
would be the worst place to do it I
think you two would be the best for long
term growth
I think Instagram would be the best for
instant growth and I would just link my
accounts from Instagram to Facebook SATA
auto post to your Facebook as well but I
wouldn't expect any major results now if
you are running an ad campaign if you
have any kind of budget if you figured
out any kind of revenue model business
model around it if you're trying to grow
your local your pastor pastor ship
congregation congregation we're making
new words today if you're trying to grow
your local congregation Facebook could
be the best paid platform to do it so I
know pastor C was in New Jersey so
whatever like a 10 mile radius is of
your location you could hit them with
your video you can make a video ad on
faith as an example what faith means to
you why people need to have more faith
in their lives right and then you could
target people who are within a 5 to 10
10 mile radius of your church and that
would go only to them and so yes you're
paying 50 cents a dollar however much
you end up paying for one person to
watch it but it's a highly targeted demo
where if you're just putting something
up on YouTube or Instagram they might be
watching from Vietnam then we were
watching from Canada it's not going to
be a client for you walking into your
business right or walking into your
church so I think Facebook is the best
ad platform in the world to go after the
the best for targeting but if you're
looking at organic reach it's the worst
all right what else we got okay back to
the tag questions Selena Gomez is the
best okay that's a good name
tips for a YouTube channel I would start
by making content like just stop
worrying about making it perfect and
work on how can you get more content out
there I believe that the quantity leads
to the quality the more you do the
better you get at anything the more you
do the better you get if you only
practice tying your shoe once a week you
would never get it like you you'd be an
adult and still not know how to tie your
shoe
so the quantity leads to the quality
stop worrying about perfection business
success is not about perfection is about
adjusting it's not about having the
perfect thing out of the gate it's about
making and then adjusting tweaking
adjusting tweaking like I said my top
ten series didn't start it was only
three years ago that my top ten series
came out and I had a channel for seven
years before that now you can do it a
lot faster than me maybe maybe I'm
stupid maybe I made a lot of mistakes
that's okay but it's not about if I
waited to have the perfect plan I would
never get started and so up up your
quantity up your quantity up your
quantity look at making as many videos
as you can as possible I would try to
get to a daily schedule at some point
don't worry so much about the perfect
message about the perfect editing just
get it up train yourself put it in your
schedule get better review your stats
see what feels right to you to make the
content and constantly improve good luck
release the perfectionist gene that took
me a long time to get out of thank you
you're welcome
next Renato should you follow your how's
our time we got nine minutes sure you
follow should you follow in your ideas
to be a regular person and go to college
should you follow in your ideas or be a
regular person go to college
it depends man depends on what you want
listen college is a fantastic if you
want to if you want to have a job that
requires a college degree you have to go
to college if you want to be a doctor
you have to go to college there's no
choice there's no other option right you
have to go to college or some jobs some
professions that you need to have a
college degree at least still right now
for you to have that success so that's
the area you want to get into then you
have to do it if you want to be an
entrepreneur then college is a
great backup plan if you want to have
your own business college is a back-up
plan if your business doesn't work out
you have a degree to fall back on if you
have to go get a job it's really hard if
you only have a high school degree so
for me I didn't know that I want to be
an entrepreneur I had a lot of
entrepreneurial tendencies growing up
and I became a real entrepreneur when I
was in university but I didn't know I
didn't absolutely know that I wanted to
be an entrepreneur and so it was still
helpful for me it was a good backup plan
if you absolutely know you want to be an
entrepreneur if you absolute like
there's no way you're ever gonna get a
job like you suck as an employee you
never want to be an employee ever ever
ever you have that absolute confidence
and clarity then the college degree is
likely not gonna help you just won't
because your customers don't care if you
have a college degree or not nobody
nobody nobody you guys don't care
nobody cares nope no brand that I work
with my publisher like nobody cares that
I went to the University of Toronto and
have an undergrad in commerce and
Finance like zero people care about that
it did not help me at all
college should be a waste of four years
of your time but that's only if you
absolutely know that you want to be an
entrepreneur if you don't know then it's
a fantastic back-up plan I'd look to do
both and I look to hack my college
experience to help me grow my business
like I did in my University treasurer
divers with the 10-pound super chat look
at that 10 pounds how many dollars is
that it's like 2.2 conversion something
like that it's like 20 dollars that's a
lot of coffees that's like that's that's
18 no not 18 eight eight or nine
coffee's on you
thank you charge of divers I really
appreciate it I'm gonna take a nice sip
for you hmm
okay question hi Evan you said
previously that it's not about the money
for me
it's all about the money for all the
pain I want some payback money is super
important money is super super super
important it just can't be number one
when you make money number one you lose
there has to be some other people you
look up to you respect the people who've
really made it who really made it there
was something above money but they
didn't make number and they didn't make
money number one hundred like
even for charity money is
super-important the charities that
suffer and struggle the ones that don't
know how to make money the businesses
that suffer and struggle are the ones
that don't know how to make money money
is really important it's just not number
one what our same before is if you make
money you're number one you'll do
short-term short-sighted stupid
decisions that will negatively impact
the long-term success of your business
so learning how to make money is really
important you just have to have
something above it so what is the
mission what are you trying to do I want
to help entrepreneurs right I want to
help a billion arch burns I want to try
to solve the world's biggest problem
that's my ambition that's what I'm
trying to do and I'm making money in the
process
like money allows me money isn't just
even about having the the house and
having the car and all that it's about
building a team like because I have
eight people who work for me on my
YouTube team I'm able to do a lot more
and will to further my mission even more
and so making money is a great thing I
think people have a have a misconception
around money some people think money is
everything it's not and some people
think money is the root of all evil it's
not money super important you need to
learn how to make money if you're an
entrepreneur it's just not number one if
you put it number one you will lose hope
that helps five minutes what are you
what are you worried about we're okay
Gabriel I'm your biggest Mexican fan and
thank you again divers for the super
chat appreciate it I'm your biggest
Mexican fan I'm facing the big problem
guard my business my wife wants me to
quit my nine year business it's I have
three terrible years I'm working to
solve it so family makes it tough I get
this a lot with parents is interesting
and on the on the husband wife side you
know you'll get to pick your parents but
get to pick the person you spend the
rest of your life with what I always
encouraging situations is having a
genuine honest conversation what I what
you need to show her is not just that of
course is gonna work out that I've this
is just three bad years of course is
gonna work out because she's gonna see
what this guy's delusional he's crazy
there's no way he's gonna work out like
look at look at the past three years it
hasn't worked out what makes this thing
who's gonna work out now showing her
that you're concerned to showing her
that this may not work out like you
try your best you feel so bad that you
had six okay years and now three years
of it not working out you you you feel
terrible but wouldn't MIT what would
make you feel worse is the rest of your
life not knowing like you have to see it
through because you will live the rest
of your life in regret and then I try to
tie it in some situation with her like
whether you met her at some coffee shop
or online or whatever and you were you
almost didn't ask her out and it has to
be a real story I'm just making
something up here but you almost didn't
ask her out and you did because you
thought you know what I might regret not
doing this and it worked out now not
every decision will work out and maybe
this business doesn't work out and you
have to figure out at some point whether
if you need to go get a job as a
part-time thing and go do your business
part-time if she needs to help out
somehow and you make it a family thing
so it's not just you doing everything
and she has her own thing like it's a
joint family thing at some point you may
come to that but what you need more than
the practical planning is the emotional
buy-in and that comes by her feeling
what you're feeling
not you fighting over various emotions
so she's got to feel the mountain of
regret that you would feel if this
business closed down before you were
ready to close it down and so it's
having not a confrontational discussion
not like oh the dogs are freaking out
dogs relax not uh you don't support me
this is my dream I need to do this why
don't you support me you're my wife
you're supposed to support me or
whatever you're yelling at each other
right I'm supposed to say you know what
I hear you and listen this may not work
out and I understand this is our family
on the line and we won't get to the
point where we're you know we're we're
poor but I know that if I don't see this
through at least give it another year or
two years or whatever it is in your head
I know that if like if I don't see this
through I'm gonna regret this for the
rest of my life I'm gonna look back on
this moment and just and just regret it
and I would really love to have your
support like I don't know I don't even
know how I do this without you because I
love you you're my wife like that tone
changed that mindset shift I think is
where you start to win and I think for
all it's the same thing with parents
it's the same thing for anybody close to
you brothers siblings
stop fighting and have a real honest
conversation next one minute
Oh quick one minute one minute one
minute nobody tagged me guys where's the
tags okay go go go tags uh provide value
yes because Mike's a fan we did that
Ivarsson on multi-level marketing okay
Emma lemon she's a business model it
gets a bad rap because because people
just think is a quick way to make money
back to the other point about money if
you're in it just from running you will
lose just look at the MLM industry or in
it just because they think they make a
quick buck you will lose the weight of
wayne in MLM well one the way to win big
is you need to have a line right it's
not from you actually selling your stuff
it's the down line and then to telling
your story like you have to actually use
the stuff that you are selling actually
use and you'll to recommend and tell a
story as to why you love it's got to be
something we would recommend to your mom
and on your page every MLM gives you
this website that is that is photocopies
everybody else on there I want to see
your picture I want to see your story I
want to know why you're starting this
business I want to know why you're using
each of these products and you have to
feel super comfortable that you would
want to recommend this to your mother
inject more humaneness inject more
personality into the product and if you
are not actually using it get out
or start using it because you will lose
if it's just trying to make money you're
gonna lose Oh
zest and glow has to show up with one
extra super chat right at the end okay
we're staying a couple minutes late
because zest and glow just gave ten
dollars so the next four coffees are on
new zest and glow my biggest struggle is
trying to manage everything to be
present everywhere YouTube Pinterest
blog instant any device for someone
who's starting up doing this full-time
by the way thank you I would honestly I
would pick one as your primary don't try
to be over there everywhere all at once
by yourself you'll end up blowing your
brains out you'll end up sucking
everywhere just put it in a mediocre
content not being able to engage as you
want to I picked the one make it great
pick the one that your audience is there
and you love doing it so for me YouTube
is my number one Instagram is now
something I'm expanding into and and
playing a lot more and and I had the
bang what to do both but I don't have
the bandwidth
to do that and Twitter and LinkedIn and
and and and all of them so I use
Instagram as my main content perform for
like pictures and stuff and then I share
that to my LinkedIn and I share that to
my Twitter and share that to my Facebook
but my primary engagement is gonna be on
YouTube and Instagram now but I've got
the patine like instagram my instagram
is relatively new in terms in my effort
level so I think at the beginning get
all the domain names I get all the
accounts get all the handles so we can
squat on you and then pick the one that
you have the most fun with for me I like
making video the best so that's why I'm
here on YouTube so much and then as you
get really good at it and you start
making money and you strip really get a
team to help you build this stuff up
then you start explaining to the other
platforms they can be try to do
everything all at once you're gonna lose
good luck you guys we're two minutes
over thank you for the love I will see
you next week next Thursday
I think otherwise you can catch me on IG
live or any other videos that come up
usually it's one o'clock for me I don't
know what time it is for you but
whatever time it is you still have a lot
of time left today to make a camp do
something you're proud of
honestly like make that your benchmark
today did you do something today that
when you put your head on the pillow and
you go to sleep at night you say today
counted today meant something like I
made something I'm really proud of today
let that be your benchmark for today
thank you guys I believe in you I hope
you continue to believe in yourself and
whatever your one word is much love I'll
see you soon